buenos dias raúl como muy bien has
comentado a libio en bruselas se ha
respirado un sentimiento de alivio tras
la victoria de emanuel macrón de hecho
apenas se supieron hallar los resultados
los presidentes de las instituciones
europeas reaccionaron muy rápidamente
todos coincidieron en que el resultado
de ayer es también un apoyo claro al
proyecto europeo uno de los dos en
reaccionar fue el presidente del consejo
europeo charles michel que aseguró que
estos cinco años europa va a poder
contar con francia lo cierto es que en
europa sería con preocupación en el caso
de que ganara marine lepén la
presidencia a pesar de que los sondeos
no lo consideraban así sí que es cierto
que el hecho de que me ganara marín
podría significar un paso hacia atrás en
el proyecto europeo bien también en su
integración también la presidenta de la
comisión europea a su labor der leyen
aseguró que juntos se hará avanzar a
francia ya europa las instituciones
europeas interpretan claramente que una
victoria de manuel macrón es también una
victoria para europa pero lo cierto es
que aquí el parlamento europeo de las
asociaciones europeas se asegura que no
es momento tampoco para la complacencia
la extrema derecha ha doblado su apoyo
en tan sólo cinco años y la unión
europea sabe que estas elecciones han
sido la última oportunidad de hecho
bruselas seguirá muy pendiente de lo que
pueda ocurrir en las elecciones
legislativas del próximo junio
así es estar yo le pregunto entonces
viendo todo este panorama cuáles se
espera que sean los principales desafíos
del segundo gobierno de macrón respecto
a la relación con europa
bueno sin duda en la actualidad estará
muy marcada para empezar la guerra en
ucrania hemos visto que manuel macro en
el ejército un importante liderazgo se
ha reunido y ha hablado en esas
ocasiones con el presidente ruso
vladimir putin así que esperamos que
sigue ejerciendo este papel de el papel
en exteriores de hecho se espera que
emanuel macrón siga apoyando que francia
siga siendo un actor clave en el juego
geoestratégico también se espera su
apoyo en la defensa de una mayor defensa
recordemos que la unión europea aprobó
recientemente la creación de un cuerpo
de acción rápida de cinco mil soldados
para actuar rápidamente en cualquier
lugar del mundo y esta es uno de los
grandes apoyos por parte de francia y
también por supuesto la economía algo
que también se ha podido ver durante
esta campaña presencial lo mucho que
preocupa la enorme inflación y también
los problemas económicos se espera que
francia sea uno de los países que siga
apoyando por ejemplo un nuevo fondo de
recuperación algo que está en debate
para poder hacer frente a la crisis
económica derivada de la guerra en
ucrania